- [Male Voiceover] Hey,
this is Moshe Kasher.
- [Female Voiceover]
And Natasha Leggero.
- [Moshe] And we just got
married six months ago.
- [Natasha] Which we think
pretty much makes us qualified
to give love advice
to strangers.
- [Moshe] So that's what we did.
We packed up the
car, hit the road,
and spread the love.
- [Both] This is
The Honeymoon Tour.
- How's breakfast?
- Luxurious.
- I've been down
there for two hours.
I found a cave down there
where there was a
sea urchin living.
- Why do you pretend like
you don't like luxury, Mosh?
You're clearly having fun here.
- You know what
that sea urchin was?
My pussy?
(Moshe laughing)
- Hell yeah.
I do like luxury,
I just don't like
the price point.
I would rather spend more
money on the vacation
and less money on...
Anyway.
I'm having a good time.
- I think we really
helped people last night.
- You really do?
- Uh-Huh.
- Yeah, what's your name?
- Maureen.
- Maureen, and?
- Russel.
- [Moshe] Do you have
something specific
you'd like to address?
- So, he doesn't like when
my dogs sleep in the bed?
- How many dogs do you have?
- Two, but they're tiny.
- Okay.
- And it doesn't matter.
- That's fair.
No, I think that's fair.
It doesn't matter
because it's not about
the size, it's about
the idea, right?
- Correct.
It's the idea, it's
the fact that they...
Bring in all this
stuff from their feet,
and they lick their own ass,
and then they're in the bed,
and then I'm just expected
to sleep there, and...
- So you have like,
anal-retentive issues?
(Audience laughing)
- OCD kind of thing.
- I am very OCD.
- I happen to sleep with
three chihuahuas, but,
he shouldn't be expected.
- You sleep with
three chihuahuas?
- I do sleep with
three chihuahuas,
yeah, I do.
Don't hug me, I like dogs.
I'm not your ally here,
I'm the opposite, I'm anal...
(Mumbling)
I like anal.
Whatever the opposite is.
- Moshe is the opposite
like he's kind of messy,
so he doesn't care.
- [Moshe] I'm a bit of a slob.
Like if Moshe makes a mess,
he runs away from it.
- We've been together
for over a year now,
and just...
I'm very committed to her,
but she doesn't like
the idea of commitment
to one person.
- Anyways about the dogs, right?
- No, no, no, no.
It doesn't work like that.
(Audience laughing)
Wait.
But that's interesting that
you're a little a bit
commitment-phobic,
but what your asking of him
is for him to become
incredibly intimate with you
by subverting his own desires,
and let these dogs in the bed.
Yes? No comment?
- You don't like the idea
of committed to one person.
- Correct.
- Are you saying
you want to be open?
- I did, but.
- But now you've found
someone you love.
That's the same with me.
And now I don't
want that anymore
because I love her so
much more everyday,
and the way in was to allow her
three dogs to sleep
in bed with me.
Here's my suggestion.
I have a suggestion.
For a month,
buy a sheet,
the dog sheet.
Okay?
Put the dog sheet
over the comforter,
while you guys are laying
in bed watching movies,
bring the dogs, they
get to hang out,
no restrictions,
then when it's time for sleep,
- And sex!
- Sleep and sex,
you bring the dogs, you
let them lick your ass.
- No, you let the dogs,
so the dogs stay up
like what he's saying,
that's good, during movie time,
and then "go to your spot"...
- Our dogs by the way,
they know the sound
of our orgasms.
Like we're like
"go to your spot,"
they're like "okay,"
and they go down there, and
we're like (cartoon noises)
Which is what it sounds
like every time I come,
and then they just
like jump back up,
they're like like "Okay,
cool, it's on again."
Can you deal with that?
- I can deal with that.
- That sounds good.
- But would you be willing
to not sleep with your dogs?
- Or any other people.
- [Natasha] It is weird
that we're in a time,
cus like, I relate to it,
where you wanna like,
sleep with a dog.
- [Moshe] Wait.
You think that...
That we're at the era
of dogs sleeping in your room?
- I think we're at the era
where dogs replace children.
For a lot of
people in their
thirties and forties,
and above.
- But I mean the
reality of that was
she wanted a polyamorous
relationship.
(Natasha laughing)
- That's true.
- The dogs represented
"everybody else".
You know what I mean?
- So you think that woman
wants to sleep with her dogs
because of her
dream of polyamory.
- I think it's like a metaphor.
You know? If she's
afraid of intimacy,
then keeping the dogs
there is a kind of
furry wedge between her,
and her furry wedge.
It's like,
you know what I mean?
Psychologically helpful for her.
I bet.
That would be my guess.
But that's so deep
in her subconscious
that only a really
brilliant psychologist
like me could see
that, you know?
- What's your name?
- I'm Erin.
- Erin. This is Aaron.
And?
- Cameron.
- [Erin] So, we've been together
the last two years,
and lived together
the last year.
But now I'm going
to UCLA in the fall,
and he's going back
to the East Bay area,
I don't know we just
kind of want, like.
Ideas or suggestions for making
a long distance
relationship work.
- Okay. And why are you
going back to San Ramon?
- I didn't do great
in school here,
so I'm gonna like,
get my shit together,
back home.
- Okay, you're at City College,
you party too hard,
and now you're going back home
to get your shit together.
- Yes.
- And you're going to UCLA...
- To meet a different dude.
(Audience laughing and oohing)
- That's what I'm worried about.
- Alright.
You know this
thing, Sleeper Bus?
It's this new thing
where you pay 60 bucks,
and you leave Oakland at like,
11 at night,
and you get into LA at
like four in the morning,
I'm gonna suggest
Sleeper Bus commitment
for three out of four
weekends, for love.
That's what I think.
- That's a good idea.
- I can do that.
- And don't get a job where
you have to work weekends
you can have those weekends off,
and you know, you
might want to...
Ask her to marry you
so she feels guilty,
so she'll never...
(Audience laughing)
- I mean honestly,
I'm not sure that's
the right idea for you,
but homie that is a
great idea for you.
One thing I will say is
that long distance
relationships over too long,
it starts to...
That whole absence makes
the heart grow fonder...
Nah.
No, UCLA makes the
pussy grow wetter.
The cute couple that
came up last night,
I felt bad for 'em.
- Right, because like.
They both clearly
moved to Santa Barbara
to try to go to school.
- They both went to Santa
Barbara City College,
he decided to major
in malt liquor.
And she decided to
do her schoolwork,
she got into UCLA.
He's moving home to
go be with his family,
probably go into
rehab or something.
And she's going to UCLA
to go join a real school
and like.
Meet her her intellectual
equals and stuff,
while he like moves back
in with his parents.
This is too mean.
- I mean.
It's the reality.
- Reality sucks.
Reality bites, I'm gonna
write a movie called that.
Seriously, I'm
thinking about it.
- Who was your favorite
couple last night?
- You and me.
(Laughing)
(Light jazz music)
- Moshe?
- Yeah?
(Natasha laughing)
- [Moshe] Let's
hit the road, bro.
We gotta drive all the
way to Palm Springs today.
That's a four and
half hour drive.
- I know.